I made it I I actually made it I'm still
alive by some miracle or maybe by sheer
luck I made it to the end of my sentence
over three months of the most horrific
work I've ever had to do with no other
alternative but it's paid off because
any minute now they'll be coming into
the dorm to let me go I can walk out of
here with my head up I can't wait to get
out of these orange overalls that I've
had to live in since I arrived it seems
like so much longer in all honesty the
only way I've been able to keep track of
how many days I've been stuck here is by
putting tally marks on the wall next to
my dormitory bed
100. I've been a member of d-class
personnel for the SCP Foundation for the
last 100 days and here's how I survived
they didn't waste any time early on I'll
give the foundation that I'd barely been
out of my sentencing hearing for a few
days put on trial and convicted for a
crime I didn't even commit or been a
string of murders and someone who had
either been involved or was responsible
laid the blame on me but whoever they
were they had powerful friends the cops
were in on it planting evidence to frame
me and make me look like I was guilty
when I was really innocent that's what
landed me in prison serving a sentence
of 25 years to Life Behind Bars and it
was during my first week of
incarceration that he showed up the
recruitment specialist a clean cut blunt
agent Smith type came to visit me I'd
even been in prison long enough to have
visitor privileges but the Shady agents
seemed to know which strings to pull in
order to ask me an important question
what would you do to get out of here
he'd said to which my answer was
anything that was my first mistake
immediately the next day I received a
letter detailing more about what exactly
agent Smith was offering it was folded
and hidden in the spine of a book that a
guard handed me during reading hour
unfolding the message it all felt like
an old school covert spy tactic to Mr
Emil karker the letter read we
understand that you've recently received
a criminal conviction there are two
options currently before you as detailed
below one you can serve out the
remainder of your sentence in prison or
two you can be released into the care of
our organization while with us you will
be helping to further scientific
advancements through hard work we've
devised A system that allows convicts
such as yourself to perform a vital role
within our organization in a return for
a reduction in their prison sentences we
have no interest in or intention of
determining any guilt for the crimes for
which you are currently convicted we
merely seek to present this opportunity
for you we ask that you destroyed this
letter once you have finished reading
should you be interested in our offer
then please recite the phrase it's a yes
to a prison guard with the badge number
47890 naturally as cryptic an offer like
that was I didn't need much time to mull
it over I was trapped in prison for
something I didn't do with no way to
appeal for my freedom or prove my
innocence so taking up a mysterious job
opportunity from a shadowy group seemed
like a much better alternative at the
time after all I cannot either work off
my sentence through employment or rot
Away In A Cell for the next two and a
half decades at minimum all I had to do
next was find the Right Guard I tried
not to make it obvious that I was eyeing
every prison guard's badge number as
they stood around keeping a close eye on
me and the other inmates but it was
while I was out in the yard that I saw
him number 47890 I'd gone to bed with a
knot in my stomach hours earlier I had
done exactly as the letter said and
approached the guard making sure I was
close enough for him to hear me but
trying to make it clear that I wasn't
looking to start any trouble either it's
a yes I told him in response 47890 had
furrowed his brow and scrunched his
mustache seemingly discussed back up
inmate he commanded sharply I backed
away with my hands raised confused as to
what just happened I spent the entire
rest of the day thinking about it maybe
the note had been a prank some kind of
initiation seeing as I was the newest
prisoner but that didn't explain the
agent who had shown up before what was
going on questions that were spinning
around to my head eventually wore me out
and while I slept that's when someone
put a bag over my head drugged me and
snuck me out of prison when I woke up I
was somewhere new a room filled with
other convicts although not many of them
seem to have come from the same prison I
had been sentenced to plenty were
sporting different jumpsuits but their
Gruff demeanors told me all I needed
about them I was surrounded by a more
violent breed of criminal some of the
worst of the absolute worst the
atmosphere in this pen full of murderers
and monsters was so tense that it felt
like the slightest accidental bump could
explode into a full-blown fight suddenly
a hatch in the ceiling opened and a pile
of clothing came thumping down from
above it was a mass of orange enough
matching overalls for every inmate in
the room of course I held back from the
initial clamor some of the others made
grabbing their new prison guard
snatching orange overalls from each
other and arguing when I eventually got
mine I noticed an unfamiliar logo
emblazoned on the front of the uniform
after being made to wait a whole day in
the pen the other prisoners and I were
filed out of the room by heavily armed
security guards we're all directed
towards a hall nobody was daring enough
to challenge the officers even the more
violent among the prisoners I spotted
that the guard's uniforms bore the same
Insignia as the overalls we'd been made
to wear must have been the logo of the
mysterious organization that had offered
me employment we were given an
orientation talk led by someone who
introduced themselves as a junior
assistant researcher they explained that
our current location was highly
classified as was the true identity of
the group that had a range for us to be
released all we were told was that this
was an unspecified form of research
facility and that we had to cooperate
with the facility staff if we wanted to
secure our release it seems
straightforward enough although the
junior assistant researchers seemed to
make a lot of jokes about us dying
during these tests I think they hoped it
would alleviate some of the tension it
didn't after sitting through the
orientation talk I still had more
questions than answers the one thing I
had Learned was that being Tattooed
Heart exiting the hall the other
prisoners and I had been Direct to get a
designation number tattooed on our wrist
and across our chest when someone had
asked why the chest the researcher
conducting orientation had answered well
in the events of an explosion it's most
likely that it will be the largest
intact chunk of meat left this was
another one of their jokes still feeling
sore as my tattoo healed I read the
number now permanently Inked onto my
body
d-2152 d-class Personnel that's what
they call the snail we were directed
into a dormitory a lot less cramped than
my old cell but still being surrounded
by violent criminals when I knew I
didn't belong there it felt no less
isolating one of them who took the bunk
next to mine introduced himself to me as
shiv Brady might try to kill me I did my
best to be friendly towards him shiv and
I didn't exactly Bond but more sprung up
conversations because there was little
else to do I was still worried about
some of the flipping comments made about
all of us dying until he pointed out
something far stranger don't you wonder
why they're making us all wait he asked
and the moment he mentioned it I did
start to wonder about that it seemed odd
that this organization had wasted little
time in getting us all here it only been
a week ago that I entered my prison cell
for the first time and now I was here I
think it's their way of telling us ship
went on that we aren't here to be
helpful to be a Workforce for them they
brought us all here to die that comment
made me look around and actually
acknowledged the people I was trapped
with they were some of the worst
criminals imaginable irredeemable
Killers with this organization really
let those people back out into the world
after helping out with a few tests I'd
soon find out because day eight was the
last before I found myself working
directly for the SCP Foundation I picked
up the name from a few places around the
facility name tags lab coats and
security uniforms always with the same
logo me and the other d-class Personnel
were woken up early in the morning by a
bell and issued with assignments from
the very first day the work started I
noticed that not all the others came
back to the dorm at the end of the day
shiv was one of those my tasks mostly
consisted of cleaning up with a mop
hosing down empty testing chambers that
had a worrying amount of blood sprayed
all over the walls and Floors the
regiments were strict and I made sure to
do exactly what was asked of me to avoid
causing any trouble it felt like a lot
like being back in prison but with the
only added caveat of being able to move
around the facility even if it was to go
and wipe up the foundation's mess
although the other classes of personnel
didn't seem to take kindly to my help
making snide comments as they passed me
in the hallways we've been told not to
address the other staff unless spoken to
which was frustrating I certainly had a
few things I would have liked to say to
them after two and a half weeks without
so much as a hint of any trouble I was
given my first testing assignment that
wasn't just cleaning up you would think
that would be exciting but having seen
some of the Carnage Left Behind after
other tests I was anything but eager to
take part luckily for me and pretty
surprisingly my first test was pretty
straightforward I was shown to a room
containing a white bowl decorated with
light blue flowers that researchers
referred to as
scp-348 I received a nasty Splinter for
my mops handle the day before and was
instructed to sit down and eat from the
bowl which was filled with soup
naturally I eagerly ate it despite how
bitter it tasted it was better than the
food from The d-class Canteen at least
but when I finished I noticed a message
had appeared at the bottom of scp-348 it
read I don't believe you were framed
goodbye son after that it was as if the
floodgates had been opened and every day
I was asked to do another test with a
new SCP most were harmless anomalous
creatures or objects like one of the
bigger experiments I was involved in
which focused on scp-999 this friendly
little gelatinous orange blob electrodes
were hooked up to me while I just calmly
sat in a room with scp-999 being around
it made me feel great the best I'd felt
since arriving and joining d-class
although I did hear one of the other
researchers making a comment that
scp-999 was quote not ready yet whatever
that meant even so the Tickle Monster
had given me a new positive outlook on
my role at the foundation it was odd
work but I could find a rhythm to it
that would hopefully make the time pass
by a little quicker and if it meant
getting out it was worth all the dirty
looks from other classes of personnel
this was an Outlook I didn't want to
lose after a month we were told to take
a pill that the guards handed out to us
something called an amnestic that would
make us all forget the previous month
but wanting to hang on to my newfound
optimism I secretly flushed mine down a
toilet in hindsight I should have taken
it my next big test quickly brought me
down a peg I was handed a katana
scp-572 and instantly felt like I was
Unstoppable the sword made me believe I
was a powerful Warrior if I could maybe
fight my way out of the foundation
facility with ease unfortunately the
moment I tried to use it didn't lead to
Freedom an accident broke my arm and
suffered a series of internal fractures
all while the research team mocked me
embarrassed and I felt like a total
laughing stock things only got worse
from there I'd barely set foot outside
of the infirmary before a different team
of personnel told me I was going to be
assisting them with an important task
they dragged me to an old wooden door
after briefly explaining what was going
on although I struggled to keep up
Beyond the Door which they called
scp-2317 was a vast salt plane following
their instructions I acted as an
assistant to the rest of the team as
they performed a strange ritual I had to
scatter a mix of holy water and chicken
blood around a circle of Seven Stone
pillars then recite blood for the old
gods water for the new king it was an
unusual practice to say the least but
apparently I was helping keep a powerful
vengeful demigod imprisoned that did
little to soften the news that I heard
when we returned through
scp-2317 when I was gone one of the
foundation's security team had been
infected by something known as
scp-2193 a phenomenon that makes people
believe that every month a large group
of d-class r2b terminated when I heard I
actually considered taking my amnestic
for this month to forget just how many
had been killed it had been a whole two
months since I had actively started work
as part of d-class personnel and there
weren't many of my fellow prisoners left
I was sent for a mandatory psychological
evaluation the foundation wanted to know
if I would still be able to perform
tests for them I doubted it came from a
place of actual concern it's not like
they cared all that much of the things I
had seen were taking a toll on me
sitting across from a researcher
performing my evaluation I did my best
impression of a normal person I had to
pretend like none of it was getting to
me all the horrors and the close brush
I'd almost had with death by monthly
termination I wouldn't have lied about
it normally but I'd been told I had a
month left before I was due to be
released apparently not many d-class
made it that far given the dangerous
nature of testing all I could think
about was how good it would feel to eat
real food again I started to daydream
about getting a cheeseburger on my first
day out almost instantly my hopes of
Freedom were dashed the very next day I
was told I'd be going on a longer
assignment this time it would be an
expedition into an anomalous location
called
scp-432 the foundation researchers
outfitted me with a flashlight plus
extra batteries a headset and a
microphone linked to their control
center were placed over my ear along
with a camera unit mounted on my
shoulder they said it would wirelessly
transmit back to them and they'd see
what I saw I was also given a couple
bottles of water some energy bars and a
few sticks of luminous marker chalk but
when they had said anomalous location
the last thing I'd been expecting was to
climb into a rusty metal cabinet the
next two weeks were like living inside a
nightmare inside the cabinet was a huge
maze a literal Labyrinth all made out of
the same rusted steel of the exterior of
scp-432 it was so dark even with the use
of my flashlight and the few light bulbs
affixed to some of the Walls Within the
cabinet mace before long I ended up
losing my bearings and lost with no way
out but being trapped in the Maze and
the dark wasn't even the worst part
there was something else in the
Labyrinth some kind of creature lurking
through the metal corridors my
flashlight eventually ran out of power
so I never actually saw it but every
time I tried to sleep I just lay awake
listening to its growls I couldn't help
but think what kind of horrible thing
was out there and might be looming over
me in the dark even when I opened my
eyes I still wouldn't get to see it
eventually another d-class was sent into
scp-432 by some miracle he was able to
not only find me but guide me back to
the entrance of the cabinet mace the
moment I was free I yelled at the
research team demanding they let me go I
didn't just mean let out of scp-432 I
meant free from d-class from the
foundation from all of it I was sent for
another psyche evaluation and deemed to
be fine just suffering from heightened
stress when they had asked me if I'd
been taking my amnestics I lied and I
told them yes 10 days before I was set
to be released and they couldn't help
but assign me to one last test downward
worry a researcher sarcastically assured
me this one will be nice and easy on you
you just have to jump into a paddling
pool you can do that can't you d2152 the
paddling pool in question was scp-120
every time a different glow emanated
from it I was instructed to jump into it
the exact second I did I found myself
transported somewhere new I got the
Himalayas on my first go Greenland and
the Sahara desert on the next two tries
every one of the locations I ended up at
had some kind of foundation facility
established nearby they'd pick me up and
I'd be taken right back to scp-120 to
continue testing it felt like I was
being deliberately intentionally
tortured the foundation was giving me
these momentary glimpses of Freedom
every time I was transported by scp-120
was a carrot on the end of the stick
that they were keeping just out of my
reach and I hated it it made me realize
that I had never been there to work for
them being part of d-class personnel
wasn't a job all I was to them was a
human lab rat but now it's my last day
it probably miss me by the end of day
today I wouldn't be here anymore I just
want to be out done with d-class for
good the foundation researchers have
given me one last simple test to do
before I go they said if I do then I'll
be gone all they wanted me to do is wear
this amulet for someone named Dr bright
how hard can that be and they said they
let me go after this one thing so can't
be anything that bad right right want to
own an SCP of your own go to scpswag.com
for previous anomalous merchandise now
go and check out what if stars are
actually exploding d-class
scp-2193 and scp-2317 the Devourer of
Worlds a door to another world for more
strange stories taken from the ranks of
the SCP Foundation